it seems like strange horror movie
cameos are about as integral to the
genre as jump scares and creepy kids
from major stars playing unusual roles
to non-hollywood celebrities
lending their star power to scream fests
here's a fond look back at the weirdest
horror movie cameos of all time
if you ever thought to yourself that
fabio with his heavenly eyes and flowing
hair looks like an angel
you're not alone the filmmakers behind
1990s the exorcist 3
apparently thought so too they cast the
young heartthrob in his first u.s role
as an angel
another bizarre cameo in the film comes
courtesy of nba star patrick ewing who
appears as the angel of death
both characters show up on screen during
a surreal dream sequence that features
an angel leading a big band
a train station that seems to be heaven
and other random acts of chaos and
madness but
that's not all the exorcist 3 has plenty
of other odd celebrity cameos including
samuel
jackson larry king and perhaps most
strangely former surgeon general
c everett coop despite its unique cameos
and
terrifying premise the film received a
lukewarm response from critics
it seems like when you're making a
second sequel to arguably the best
horror movie ever made
you have to make it stranger if you
can't make it any scarier
these days bill murray's public demeanor
seems to be closer to his classic
characters in ghostbusters and
caddyshack
than the persona of most a-list actors
this is why it was such
a delight to see the legendary comedian
appear in zombieland
playing a slightly exaggerated version
of himself
i mean who's bill murray i've never hit
a kid before
i mean that's like asking who gandhi is
while zombieland is a horror comedy
murray's cameo completely changes the
tone of the movie from
slightly scary to nearly pure comedy as
the four main characters wander into
murray's seemingly abandoned mansion
the set design is pure murray myth
featuring props from his previous movies
and ludicrous paintings of the men
hanging throughout the house it's the
perfect foreshadowing for when murray
himself
eventually pops up and he's in
surprisingly good spirits for someone
who's survived the zombie apocalypse for
so long
murray ends up having a blast with the
protagonist right up until a prank goes
wrong
in an extremely gruesome way it's by far
the comedic
centerpiece of a very funny movie and
zombieland wouldn't be the same without
the surprise
of seeing the beloved actor delivering
some truly classic lines
so do you have any regrets
garfield maybe silence of the lambs is
one of the greatest horror movies
ever made and also one of the few to
ever earn an academy award
many factors led to that critical
acclaim the steady direction of jonathan
demi
the nuanced performance of jody foster
and of course
the scenery chewing flesh-eating
character of
hannibal lecter played by anthony
hopkins it's an incredibly engrossing
movie but
if you're a mega fan of crooning
songwriter chris isaac
you might get pulled out of the movie
when he suddenly shows up on screen
isaac the musician behind the hit song
wicked game
appears towards the end of the film as a
swat commander during lector's breakout
scene
it's an incredibly tense and climactic
moment in the film that
unfortunately might be lessened for you
if you spend most of the scene going
wait was that chris isaac of course
isaac has appeared in other films since
most notably in david lynch's twin peaks
fire walk with me but his cameo in
silence of the lambs is
definitely one of his most surprising
appearances
while some viewers might find it jarring
plenty of movie fans had
another reaction that was good
the backstreet boys warned us all along
that they'd be back
but we still didn't believe them or at
least we didn't think that they'd be
back in the closing minutes of this is
the end
in this star-studded horror comedy most
of the action takes place around james
franco's house
as real-life celebrities are menaced by
supernatural events
and insane survivors of the rapture
perhaps
unsurprisingly the rapture doesn't
include a decent chunk of the hollywood
elite
leaving jonah hill seth rogen james
franco danny mcbride
craig robinson and jay barrishaw to haul
up and hide from demons
eventually baroshell and rogan are able
to ascend to heaven
where they can have everything they've
ever dreamed of
just by wishing for it barrishell in a
truly relatable moment
wishes for the backstreet boys to show
up and perform one of their biggest hits
they say that horror and comedy both
rely on surprise so
it makes sense that a horror comedy
would end with one of the most
surprising and danceable cameos of all
time
sometimes it's not the actual presence
of a celebrity in a horror movie that's
surprising but
rather how they use that celebrity
instead of getting wrapped up in the
ambiance of the film
you end up scratching your head
wondering what the purpose of such a
bizarre cameo even was
a perfect example is tim burton's 1999
adaptation
of sleepy hollow which cast christopher
walken as the headless horseman
let's be specific here however watkin
plays
the headless horseman before he loses
his head in other words he plays
a horseman word play aside watkins
character doesn't utter a single line of
dialogue during his brief appearance in
the film
instead he growls and hisses while
fighting and trying to escape capture
considering the unique joy of watkins
voice it's
completely insane to cast the acclaimed
actor
in a dialogue-free role where he only
snarls and grunts
you almost certainly know tommy wiseau
for his cult-hit film
the room in which he delivers a truly
inimitable bizarre
performance you are tammy part lisa
wyzo has the kind of strange charisma
where
no matter what you're genuinely
distracted when he appears on screen
which was bad news for 2016's cold moon
despite wyzo's cameo and a story by the
writer of beetlejuice
cold moon is definitely not a comedy in
fact it's deathly serious which makes
his
cameo even stranger in the horror drama
wiseau appears for just a few moments
with the snake and he performs as if
he's never seen one before in his life
there's almost nothing more surprising
than seeing wyzo in an
otherwise straightforward dramatic
horror movie especially when his
presence bends the movie like
gravity having him appear in the first
10 minutes of the film
just means that the audience is going to
spend the next 80 minutes
wondering if he's ever coming back
you must be kidding aren't you
technically this is less of a cameo and
more of a small role but
jack black's performance as an overly
familiar weed dealer named titus and i
still know what you did last summer
is weird enough to merit inclusion at
the time of the film's release black
hadn't yet reached the heights of fame
he'd scale after his work in school of
rock and kung fu panda but he was still
recognizable for his role in the
tenacious d
television show and other small movie
parts the sequel to i know what you did
last summer
takes the surviving characters to the
bahamas for a vacation
where they once again have to fend off
the evil advances of the maniac from the
first movie
black's titus is one of the killer's
first victims as he stabbed with a hook
and then
impaled with garden shears to his credit
black
totally commits to the part giving titus
a lot of presence on screen
although at times it feels as if black
is behaving like he would on
any given day
the original scream more or less
reinvented the horror genre
pushing mainstream horror out of the
cookie cutter rut that it had been stuck
in for so long and giving audiences
characters that had at least seen a
horror movie before
even if that knowledge didn't keep them
from falling prey to a killer
as with most successful horror films
scream created its own franchise which
led to the well-received
scream 2 but then started to peter out
with scream 3.
still the second sequel does offer one
delightful surprise cameo
carrie fisher playing an annoyed studio
secretary named bianca who bears an
uncanny resemblance to carrie fisher and
was almost cast in star wars
i was up for princess leia i was this
close
so who gets it the one who sleeps with
george lucas
fisher's cameo is a welcome surprise in
an otherwise pretty lackluster film
and there's plenty to enjoy and fisher
playing a character that's mistaken for
fisher in a movie franchise that jumps
between movie fiction
and movie reality from start to finish
the cabin in the woods seems to be
obsessed with cataloging and referencing
the formula of horror movies
nearly every scene in the film either
directly references or
obliquely nods to popular horror
conventions or even specific horror
flicks
that extends all the way to the climax
in which dana and marty find out that
they're all part of a grand
ongoing sacrifice which requires certain
archetypes to be ritualistically killed
for the pleasure
of elder gods marty needs to die since
he's the fool
while the virgin can survive without
ruining the ceremony
it's a pretty clear nod to the final
girl convention
a term coined by writer carol clover in
her book
men women and chainsaws gender in the
modern horror film
naturally the director of the institute
in charge of sacrificing people for
elder gods
is a final girl in her own right someone
who survived a killer
except you might have expected the part
to be played by jamie lee curtis
one of cinema's most notable scream
queens from classic slasher films like
halloween
the character is instead played by
sigourney weaver it's a really
surprising cameo mostly because weaver's
role in the alien franchise doesn't
exactly line up with cabin in the
woods's central statement
about formulaic horror conventions
curtis's place in the popular
horror consciousness would have been a
much more obvious choice while
weaver's cameo almost undercuts the
central point of the film
sometimes breaking the fourth wall in a
movie works like a charm and adds an
extra dimension to the narrative but
when said wall is unexpectedly smashed
to pieces by a professional wrestler who
has nothing to do with the rest of the
film
it can be a little jarring the 1984
horror comedy gremlins gets pretty weird
in some places in the 1990 sequel
gremlins 2 the new batch
takes the craziness to another level joe
dante's satire of hollywood sequels is
full of easter eggs and cameos but
the most memorable and bizarre comes by
way
a former wwe superstar hulk hogan
when the little terrors commandeer a
movie theater that is somehow
showing gremlins 2 the manager of the
theater seeks help from hogan
who happens to be in the audience after
getting worked up about the film being
interrupted by gremlins
the hulkster addresses the annoying
green creatures before he pile drives
the fourth wall
if i were you i'd run the rest of
gremlins too right now
sorry folks it won't happen again
there are so many weird celebrity cameos
in sharknado 3 oh
hell no that you'd be forgiven for not
spotting them all upon your first
viewing
shaw's of sunset cast member rezafarahan
plays a capital park policeman
former malcolm in the middle star
frankie muniz appears as a mechanic
george r.r martin can be spotted as a
moviegoer even penn and teller have a
short scene in a diner with david
hasselhoff the list
goes on and on but the one celeb cameo
that seemed to have
everyone talking after sci-fi dropped
the b-movie sequel in 2015
involved tv's jerry springer in
sharknado 3 oh hell no
the east coast has been re-christened
the feast coast by the press
this is because there's a massive
sharknado headed in that direction
knowing that his wife april and their
family are spending the day at universal
orlando
veteran sharknado hunter finn shepherd
heads for florida
along the way he's joined by nova an
expert sharknado tracker
upon arrival the pair walked straight
into a nightmare the famous theme park
is plunged into chaos when the sharknado
finally hits
in the middle of the mayhem springer's
character really wants his picture taken
next to a replica of the shark from jaws
unfortunately for him it's not a prop
please here
take my picture please please take my
pictures
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you